hello and welcome to pi data global 2021
my name is natalie and i'm very happy to
be here and to be your host for this
session i would like to now welcome
jacqueline no no lease and chase cancer
to our session and they will talk about
enterprise machine learning pipelines
with unstructured image data dr nolis
has over 15 years of experience in
managing data science teams and projects
at companies ranging from dsw to airbnb
she currently is the head of data
science at
saturn cloud where she helps design
products for data scientist chase
ginther has also spent his career
working on a wide variety of machine
learning projects and is particularly
passionate about mlaps and ml platforms
prior to joining snowflake he was the
engineer man engineering manager leading
deloitte's ai center of excellence
platform engineering team and with that
i will give the floor to dr no
nolis and chase thank you so much for
joining us today i appreciate the intros
and and we'll jump right in we know we
only have you know 30 minutes today uh
you know for our session so we certainly
want to leave time for a couple
questions and answers um
at the end so we'll jump right in
um so with that um on the next slide we
actually have a link here to how you can
follow along with a lot of the material
today um at the beginning here we're
going to start with some background
information so
feel free to go ahead and pull this up
and then as we start to get into a
little bit more of the quick start and
actual like technical demo you can start
to follow along at the length that's on
the screen now
all right
okay folks just a second to grab that
and if you don't want to follow along
and just listen to us talk that is also
acceptable you will still get value out
of this talk so
absolutely and then we'll have this link
again as well at the end so if you'd
like to just listen and then do it you
know take it home for later
that's also great
and here we go
awesome yep
so um we're gonna start today's session
by just uh doing a little bit of
background on what is snowflake
um
so you know snowflake is really a cloud
data platform that we believe is one of
the best platforms for machine learning
today
um you know it's what it's allowing
organizations to do it's allowing you
know a single platform to make all
relevant data instantly accessible
to data scientists so this spans
structured data semi-structured data and
what we're going to be focusing about in
this talk unstructured data this is a
really powerful
concept because you know the idea that
you can have that single platform to
access and query all of those different
data types doesn't necessarily exist
today um you know there's a lot of
hybrid solutions you may have to have
different tools to work with all those
different uh data types
we are really focused on accelerating oh
just one backbone sorry i got too
excited
no worries
um so data processing for future
engineering or model inference you know
can be accelerated with snowflake
without any of the operational burden
regardless of the scale that you need to
operate uh or the complexity of the
number of concurrent users we have fully
managed uh intelligent infrastructure
that doesn't require any tuning so the
days of going into uh tune the number of
executors for your spark cluster that
doesn't happen with snowflake we manage
that all entirely for you you simply
just need to size uh the compute uh you
know correctly for your warehouse and
that can of course be a little bit of an
iterative exercise but you know you
don't have to jump in and continue to
tune it from there
we also provide
tools and the developer you know
kit of choice so if you want to use uh
sql you know that's what a lot of our
you know snowflake was really built
around of course we support that most
recently we've announced something
called snowpark uh which is really our
data frame api that we are exposing in
python java and scala for you to be able
to manipulate data
locally but all the data stays within
snowflake and you're able to
do all that transformation using
snowflake compute
and we can go to the next slide
great
and again so snowflake is really that
one single platform to access all of
that all those different data types
so if you think about this from a
governance perspective in your
organization being able to have that
single source of truth with one single
governance pattern you don't have to go
and submit access requests to 13
different systems just to build your
machine learning model because you need
to pull in all these different data
sources um that problem goes away
and it also integrates with all the
existing tools and
for your machine learning ecosystem uh
so you know today we're going to be
showing that with saturn cloud of course
but you know whatever your ml toolkit of
choice is
i guarantee that we have a way that we
can integrate with that
all right next slide
and um so you know to that end we have
native connectors for python r and spark
uh so if you're running a smart workload
you can you know use our spark connector
to connect when snowflake can be your
data platform for your spark workload um
again you could use our new snowpack
libraries to be able to uh you know
transform and manipulate your data
where our goal is to really simplify the
ml ops process
um so we want to make it really easy to
expose
machine learning models to your entire
organization or those that should have
access at least
so what this looks like is you could
actually deploy a machine learning model
behind and
create a function within snowflake so if
somebody um you know like an analyst at
your enterprise can go in and write a
sql query and call that function from
within their sql query that's actually
you know calling a machine learning
model or even a pipeline to that model
to do transformation and then get a
result back uh really democratizing ai
there
and of course being able to do that with
again within the confines of that one
single managed platform increasing trust
uh you know and and a fully governed
process for you and we can go to the
next slide
um we truly do believe we're one of the
fastest processing engines with no with
the least amount of operational overhead
um so we truly believe that we are the
best engine for doing pre-pro data
pre-processing for your machine learning
workloads um we'd love for you to put it
to the test you know bring your
workloads over we'd love to do to do
some benchmarking uh but once you have
the data in snowflake you're able to use
tools like snowpack use tools like sql
to do all your future engineering and
then plug into your partner tool of
choice for your training
and we can go to the next slide
and so what this looks like and there's
a couple of flexors jacqueline sorry
just like
we did yeah i got that i'll put them all
in there perfect perfect thank you
the saturn cob logo is the important one
so um we
again just to kind of put this whole
picture together here of where snowflake
provides native capabilities for machine
learning today we are really focused on
the data problem right we are not
necessarily a
native model training platform that's
what you're going to use a tool like
saturn cloud for uh but what we are is
we again we really believe we're the
best data platform and that's where we
see most of the
headaches for the machine learning
process coming in right the data
management the the data ops piece of the
machine learning process so
um you know we hope this sort of image
helps put it
put everything together that you'll use
snowflake for all your data preparation
when you're ready to train your model
you plug into a partner you could either
deploy the model with that partner such
as saturn cloud or in the you know
whatever other machine learning tool you
may be using you can deploy it there you
can also deploy it natively within
snowflake as well behind a udf
as i was describing earlier and you'll
also use the ml platform for the
monitoring piece um
so again just hoping to put all that
together and we go to the next slide
and now i'm going to hand it over to
jaclyn yeah okay so given all that and
all about snowflake and storing data now
let's shift gears a little bit
i talk about actual engineering
enterprise machine learning pipelines so
how do you actually do machine learning
in an enterprise in prague
so when i think enterprise machine
learning pipelines and i think that all
the time i think about two totally
really kind of like totally different
steps that kind of have to go on the
first step is your model training right
you have some training data
you make a model training script that
trains it in some way and then you from
there create a fitted model and like
you'd be like oh that's three steps
that's pretty straightforward and
obvious but that's actually already
fairly complicated right because the
training data often comes from many
different places right throughout your
org some of the data might be structured
some of it might not be some of it you
have to use a sql query to get some of
it you have to connect to an api it's
like getting the data is
complicated and then you know you have a
fitted model you make a transcript you
fit a model you may have to fit a model
multiple times right you may once a
quarter decide to retrain it manually
you may automatically retrain it you
know an automated once a day retraining
something like that that can get fairly
complicated but even let's say you do
have a fitted model
you then have your prediction steps
where okay how are you going to actually
use this model to provide value well one
thing you can do and lots of enterprises
do is you have some sort of bulk
inference process right so if you're a
company with 70 million customers and
you train a model to predict customer
churn whatever
you maybe once a month re-predict all
those 70 million customers so you got to
take that fit in model you got to do a
bulk prediction job of hey here's a
massive amount of data fit the model
have the model run correctly on that
and then get some results from there and
save those results in a way that is
actually useful to the company so like
save them back to the database that
stored the training data one of the
training data sets
or sorry not training data that's one of
the inference bulks data sets you could
also just as easily imagine scenarios
where customers have to do real-time
predictions so they have the spin and
model and then the moment a customer
shows up they have to predict their
churn right after every order the moment
they do that that could be via a rest
api that you then use to host a model
like flask something like that or you
know as chase was saying you could like
put into snowflake these sort of systems
where the moment of row is written into
your database it automatically fires
these models but these end up being
fairly complicated and they end up being
even more complicated if your data is
coming from a lot of different sources
with like different ways of querying and
different complexities and especially
with unstructured data which like
doesn't fit into your standard database
model
which we're going to focus on especially
today in this talk
um so why are enterprise machine
learning pipelines hard well one the
data is often unstructured it's complex
it's messy it comes from a lot of places
and you know it may not just fit into
your database
um two you're probably going to connect
to a lot of different things those
connections need to be stable and secure
because if like you know one of those
connections goes down and you're trying
to predict 70 million customers and you
know one of the databases your model
needs suddenly isn't working like that's
really bad like these and you know maybe
from models outputs don't exist prod
systems go down your netflix model
doesn't make recommendations anymore
like that stuff's really bad this
stuff's important um and those models
they have to be quick it can't take
forever to run the models because a lot
of times these are real time or if you
have to predict 70 million customers
that's bad um and like you may like i
said you may want to think thought like
think carefully of how you do retraining
because your models will eventually get
stale and you need to be ready for that
so that all adds a ton of complexity to
enterprises in a way that like your you
know standard side project may not have
so
we're going to talk through one of these
examples and the example that uh i'm
going to use here presented by snowflake
and saturday cloud i tried to make this
look like an old-timey title screen i
don't know if that came across what i
was going for but the idea is let's talk
about example enterprise pipeline and
how they work through these problems
with unstructured data and let's do it
by imagining a scenario where you have
to classify images of garments so you
have some number of pictures of clothing
you want to classify them that one's a
dress that's a shirt that's a skirt
that's a shoe i'm very good at this you
you want to classify all of these and
you want to do it in a way that you can
then save that data but also these
images you probably can't just get them
from a database because images are
generally unstructured data right they
don't they're not like a row column
format generally and this is like a good
example you can imagine that is one form
of unstructured data this could get far
more unstructured but like this is just
a very nice easy example and this is
like a real practical application
nordstrom stitch fixed lots of companies
that have to do with you know retail
clothing have to categorize that
clothing and they have to categorize
images that maybe they get from custom
reviews and things like that
um so this is a real
problem um
so that's what we're going to set out to
do
and so what would that look like as an
enterprise pipeline well here's one
hypothetical example so one you could
use something like snowflake
unstructured
unstructured data sets to store that
training data
you take those chaining images and you
paste
you you send them to a place where you
train your model in our case because i
work at saturn cloud i'm going to use
saturn cloud as a place i can run models
you could run models pretty much
anywhere um so just for the sake of
argument let's say a center cloud but
you're not limited to that in any way
once you create your model
you then have some sort of at some level
this is a mathematical function that
takes this image and returns a
classification of it you store that in a
useful place and then you go into your
predicting step where in our case let's
say we have a massive on let's say we're
doing the bulk version of this so we
have a massive unstructured data set of
images stored in snowflake which i then
have to pull into bulk i have to score
those very quickly so i'm going to use
das
which we'll get to what task is
to in parallel predict all these things
at once take the results and save them
back to that snowflake data set so that
um it's very easy to look at both the
image and what the prediction is
so quick aside what is saturn cloud
saturn cloud is your data science
environment uh basically saturn cloud is
a place where you can do machine
learning data science um it's you know
it's got built-in jupyter labs you can
run you know run notebooks on instances
between you know with with gpus or desk
clusters or um four terabytes of ram um
you can run the stuff in production we
can schedule jobs and deployments host
dashboards and apis you can use admin
tools to help manage a team so that you
can easily transfer you know you don't
have a model that only works on your
laptop and no one else can use it and
you can connect anywhere so you can use
jupyter lab built in or you can use um
ssh and you know connect via vds code or
whatever but the point is this is a very
nice easy tool if you want to run
machine learning models um or train them
um and i work there so i like it
um so that's the premise of what we're
gonna do and i'm gonna pass it back to
chase so just talk a little bit more
about how we're gonna actually store
that data in an unstructured way and
then how it will then you know flow back
to the modeling side
perfect all right next slide yeah so
again using unstructured data like what
makes unstructured data special um is
typically very different than you know
firing up your sql ide and writing a
query select star from you know table
right it is uh your unstructured data is
typically sitting in object storage it
is folder or multiple folders full of
files with very minimal um you know or
no metadata and most of the time these
services that you are storing your
unstructured data in don't provide any
sort of uh you know layer over top to
actually help you query that data or or
find it and retrieve it um so you know
snowflake our our position in this space
is to really bridge that gap um where
you're still using that underlying
object storage but we're providing the
layer on top to make the management of
it and integration with your other data
sets much easier next slide
uh so again you know unstructured data
lives outside of snowflake like s3 we
can connect to that and provide our
query engine directly over top
to be able to integrate that with the
rest of your data so it's not just s3 if
you're in google uh it's you know the
same thing the same object storage in
google uh same thing in azure it's just
using the major cloud providers they're
underlying object storage
next
so what does this look like so the first
thing you're going to do is you are
going to create a stage um and uh you're
going to in this case we're actually
going to use an external stage so that
means you already you're managing the s3
bucket uh and you know this case right
aws so you're managing the s3 bucket
snowflake is not so that means you have
to give us the credit uh you need to
give us access to it so one way is that
you can give us aws credentials to an i
am role but we could also just establish
an i am trust relationship as well um
and this is what is what allows us to
authenticate with you know your bucket
some of the data scientists the room
probably don't necessarily care that
much but your cloud architects and your
security engineers that work at your
company uh very much so care um and then
you're going to run a very simple
command just like this
and then next slide and again all of
this is in the quick start in the link
that we sent out so you're you know
don't worry about trying to like capture
this it's all there for you
and then what you're going to do is
you're actually going to set up a
database and so what this is going to do
is point to the data that is still
sitting in your s3 bucket uh but we will
capture real parts of
all the information available about that
data
and log that metadata and in here for
example let's if we're going to do uh
classification and we're going to create
some predictions we're going to go to
create a table that will uh hold in a
column that will hold that
prediction for us and we can insert a
time stamp so that way you know if we
ever need to go back and update that
prediction we know when that prediction
was updated um we also provide uh
pre-signed urls and that's what you'll
see of how you can actually retrieve
that data from that underlying s3 object
storage
all right and back over to you jaclyn
great okay so let's assume we've set
those images up those clothing garment
images they live in s3 let's say we've
set up a snowflake um unstructured data
connection so that we can query
snowflake to get the images that are
unstructured to use in our model
um so we now need two things
one we need a training notebook right
which will load the unstructured
clothing from snowflake we'll chain a
pie torch model use a gpu save the model
um
you could run this script by hand on a
jupiter server um or you could set a
schedule to automatically do this on
newer more recent training data
periodically whatever but you need one
trading strip and then you in our case
we need our bulk prediction script um so
this is going to again load the data
unstructured data from snowflake and
again this is loading image data but you
can imagine for a full enterprise
pipeline is probably loading in the
images and like
when they were uploaded and blah blah
blah like eight things from eight
different data sets
um and then we also have to load up the
model file we created in step one
then in our case because assume we're
going to be training on you know let's
say millions of images at once and we
want to not be able to do that not just
have one machine doing that we're going
to use das to do it in parallel then
we're going to take the results and save
them back to the snowflake database and
again this could be run by hand if you
wanted for some reason you could also
set it around on a schedule or you could
you know either convert this to an api
to you know actually just run one image
at a time or you can make an api that
you hit every time you want the bulk
inference to be done there's a lot of
ways you could actually deploy this
so
if you want
uh again just would like to lightly
promote that you can use saturn cloud
for free to do this you got 30 hours of
a 64 gig gigabyte instance or three um
and three hours of dash a month or you
can get 16 gigabytes of ram and a gpu
you got yeah stuff there so so the point
is we load the data in and as chase was
saying because the data isn't actually
in snowflake it's in aws s3 we aren't
loading directly from snowflake what we
are doing is we are getting from
snowflake a pre-signed url so that
pre-signed url is a secure way we can
get that data from aws and you'll be
like why would i not just want to
connect to aws directly to get this data
great question well the reason why is if
you can imagine in an enterprise setting
we don't want just every machine
learning model having full access to an
aws s3 bucket and things like that it's
kind of like for a security perspective
and just like data governance
perspective it's nice to kind of have
snowflake as the later layer you use for
doing your data accessing and usage
rather than sometimes pulling in
snowflake and sometimes pulling directly
from aws s3 so like there's a nice layer
of um a nice way to kind of lower the
complexity and get everything from one
place
so in our case what we're going to use
is we're going to use snowflake to get
those pre-signed urls to tell us where
to get the data from
and so in python we get the present urls
and then we just you know do a request
to that url
and then those quick urls you know
expire and such forth so that's like a
ephemeral artifact of this um
and so then okay let's say we loaded
that data in so what are we going to do
in this case it's an image
classification model so let's use
convolutional neural networks uh a super
aside a convolutional neural network is
basically saying okay we're going to
look at each pixel in the image and then
look at the pixels around it and try and
infer something from that and then we're
going to take those inferences and infer
things from local groups of that so you
can kind of see here you take one pixel
gets you look at an area of it and you
look at an area of those and you look at
various and eventually get down to one
output
classification there are many types of
neural network layers this is one of
them that works particularly well for
image recognition and text um work um
and so the point being we are
and each one of these layers is
basically a whole bunch of linear
regressions so basically we are bringing
a bunch of linear regressions together
to take an image and turn it into a
classification um
we do this using pi torch we run this
quickly on gpus just so it's much faster
to train um and so we do that and let's
suppose we create ourselves a classifier
but instead of cat and dog in this case
it will be telling us which of the
classifications of images we want um
you know shoe dress etc
um so then let's say we change that
model where do we save it um in the
quick start and just like for this
hypothetical example you can like just
save it locally like save it to a file
and then upload that to s3 or whatever
you know um just save it locally but in
an enterprise setting you actually want
to be much more thoughtful on where you
save your models you could save them to
places like snowflake you could save
them to other places
the issue with these models is you
really it's actually quite complex to
keep track of the models because you
really want to keep track of the
versions of the models right when did
you make the model what data did you use
to do it things like that you want to
keep track of what inputs went into the
model right you can imagine you know
maybe three months in you change it so
that the images instead of being square
on input they're now rectangles like you
want to keep track of like how your
model is actually expecting its input
data which changes over time
you also want to model the monitor the
model performance so if you keep saving
models and the accuracy is getting lower
and lower you want to notice that um
there's like a thousand other things
like this you really want to keep track
of
um which is all to say that saving a
model feels like it should be the
easiest stuff in the process but i
submit it as the hardest step in the
process um this is a whole thing right
there are people there are companies
there are people who spend their whole
careers like there are people spend
their whole careers companies who are
entirely invested to thinking about how
to do this well um you should do that
too if you're an enterprise i would say
um but that's not really the point of
what we're going to talk about today
this is just an aside of like please
take this step seriously
um so then let's say you train the model
and now let's talk about doing the
actual bulk predictions
um
so again you load up the data just like
before from aws through snowflake and
then in our case we're doing saturn
cloud but wherever you're going to want
your model to run
and then in our case we're going to use
das das is a really cool powerful open
source tool that can
entirely in python do things in parallel
in a distributed cluster and so in our
case we're going to have saturn cloud
like running a jupiter server that's
using das client and then farming that
out to a cluster of das workers so you
can do your complex thing in parallel
and your inference will run much faster
um this is great um desk is built into
saturn's cloud again there are other
places you can run it but it's a really
nice tool if you're like i want to run
something that's really slow really
quickly um das and you'd like and i
don't want to go through the effort of
setting up a spark cluster and stuff
like das is a really nice way to do
and then it
we then can once we have the predictions
we can then update the data in snowflake
so at its core that unstructured data is
still a table with the pre-signed urls
and things like that and and we can just
add the columns for the inferences and
like what the confidence was and things
like that we're gonna save that back in
just like it was sql so it's nice to
save your results right to where the
input is and so just you use an update
query in python to do that
um
so that's kind of the gist
the takeaways here is that
that's kind of what an enterprise
pipeline looks like you can use the
unstructured file storage stuff of
snowflake to let you really nicely which
you know those new features to get that
nice level of control and security when
you're doing you know loading in like
files from aws or unstructured stuff
that won't fit in a database um and you
can use saturn cloud if you want to do
the machine learning stuff of that
although you can do that anywhere too um
it's just a nice way to access that um
and
once you have that model that you've
made you can um you can run it and then
save those results back to snowflake and
you get a nice nice loop of take your
data run your models put it back take
your data run your model put it back um
and that could be a really powerful tool
um so with that thank you so much um i
want to make sure i i got a little fast
at the end because i really want to
leave time for question but as stated at
the beginning you can get our code is
available at scld that's short for
soundcloud.io scld.io snowflake quick
start or pi data 2021 snowflake for the
actual slides you're looking at right
now
um
um our time with you is over
um thank you so much jacqueline and
chase for your talk and for being part
of pi data glow of 2021.
thank you
awesome thanks everyone